[Music]  let's talk about a season to Vickie  Aubry fans in my household what kind of  feedback are you getting on season two  good great feedback yeah a lot of people  like it most people like it was great  [Music]  the mind flayer a lot the mind flayer a  lot of people ask if he's still there  cuz if you notice in the last episode a  piece of it leaves a will but it doesn't  go out the portal so there's still kind  of a connection there for season three I  think oh my god I'm gonna hang on to  that I love that and that makes sense to  me I love when things make sense let me  ask you this you guys are always sort of  jacked where you're meeting celebrities  and things like that who are you excited  to see tonight perform what do they just  meet tonight even just hey I really  wanna meet Bruno Mars I mean he's doing  great  [Music]  you